good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the war in Ukraine began
a year ago today on February 24 2022
when the Russian military rolled across
the eastern border of that country but
in many ways the Russian invasion of
Ukraine was the end point of a much
longer story The propaganda campaign
designed to convince Americans to take
sides in this conflict a conflict that
has nothing strictly speaking to do with
them or with America that effort began
many years earlier
we'd Peg it to July 22nd 2016. that's
the day that Wikileaks published
thousands of emails from the servers of
the Democratic National Committee in
Washington
those emails prove that party officials
had rigged the Democratic process the
primary process in favor of Hillary
Clinton and against the Insurgent
populist candidate that year Bernie
Sanders of Vermont within days the chair
of the DNC Debbie Wasserman Schultz
resigned in disgrace the Wikileaks
Scandal broke on the same day that
Hillary Clinton chose her running mate
Senator Tim Kaine and it overshadowed
the nominating convention that followed
but more significantly the Wikileaks
Scandal threatened to split the
Democratic party into pieces more than
13 million Bernie Sanders voters many of
the young people learned that the
process they had always believed in was
in fact a sham they had been cheated
Democratic leaders had to act quickly in
the face of this to deflect blame from
themselves onto someone else
the dnc's servers they claimed had been
hacked by the Russian military the goal
was to hurt Hillary Clinton whom the
Russians feared for her strength and
wisdom and to help Donald Trump whom
they controlled Russia hacked the
servers in order to hack the election
that was their story The Washington Post
ran with it the first day as if it were
true
but there was never any evidence that it
was true almost seven years later there
is still no evidence the dnc's story
about its servers is a lie
but as a political strategy that lie
worked flawlessly Russia made the
perfect villain it was a white Christian
country with a traditional social
structure it was everything the
Democratic party already opposed
the foreign policy apparatus in
Washington was happy to hate Russia
again after 40 Years of Cold War hating
Russia was muscle memory
so soon the leaders of both parties in
Washington signed on to the Russia
collusion hoax it had the twin benefits
of paralyzing the Trump Administration
which it did and justifying the
expansion of the National Security State
as the years passed in the rhetoric
intensified hysteria set in after a
while anybody with a heterodox opinion
from right Wingers to avowed socialists
could be accused of working secretly for
Vladimir Putin many were accused and
some were destroyed by it it was a
textbook Witch Hunt far more effective
than McCarthyism and unlike McCarthyism
it never ended Russia remained America's
greatest enemy even as China emerged as
America's greatest threat
over time the lie that Democrats told to
hide their crimes in the 2016 primaries
came to dominate America's foreign
policy and then to imperil America
itself
for Generations Statesmen and diplomats
worked to prevent other great powers
from aligning as a block against the U.S
the idea was pretty straightforward you
might be able to beat one strong country
but if a couple of strong countries ever
got together you would lose this is why
Richard Nixon went to China to make sure
the Chinese government didn't align with
Brezhnev with the Russians
Donald Trump understood this very
clearly Russia will never be our closest
Ally he said but if Russia ever becomes
China's Ally we're in deep trouble the
combination of Natural Resources
military and economic power and sheer
population would make the Russian
Chinese Alliance the most powerful force
in the world the United States would
soon be dethroned we'd be taking orders
As Trump put it there is no reason to
make Russia our enemy and there are many
reasons not to
it was a sound case but official
Washington ignored him their response
shouted in unison shut up Putin stooge
and then they set about trying to
provoke a war with Russia now they have
succeeded
but the war we're fighting in Ukraine is
not against Russia alone but also
against Russia's newest Ally the
People's Republic of China
what Donald Trump predicted has happened
and in the worst way
if the war in Ukraine continues we will
lose No Matter How It Ends the world
order is being reshuffled as we watch
and by the time it's over the U.S will
no longer be at the top of the deck
that is very obvious to the rest of the
world but what's fascinating is how few
Americans seem to understand what's
happening or its consequences but how
would they know no one in American
politics or media will tell them the
truth
since the first hours after the invasion
Americans have been fed a steady diet of
increasingly absurd lies about Ukraine
Google and Facebook have joined with the
Biden Administration to censor any
factual information that contradicts the
official storyline it's dystopian
Joe Biden's first remarks about the war
gave no hint that we would be sending
Advanced Weapons Systems an American
Military advisers to Ukraine then
supporting the entire Ukrainian
government and its pension system with
hundreds of billions of U.S tax dollars
no Joe Biden mentioned only sanctions
which are free sanctions he suggested
would be enough here is Joe Biden a year
ago today
the Russian military has begun a brutal
assault on the people of Ukraine
without provocation without
justification without necessity this
aggression cannot go unanswered if it
did the consequences for America would
be much worse
America stands up the bullies We Stand
Up For Freedom Putin is the aggressor
Putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
today I'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions
strong sanctions that'll do it now the
goal at that point a year ago today you
may remember this was to push Russian
forces back into their own country to
reverse the invasion and that seemed
reasonable to most people it did not
seem like the beginning of a third world
war oh but it was exactly that and by
December Lindsey Graham was confident
enough to say so out loud here he is
how did this war end when Russia breaks
and they take Putin out anything short
of that the war is going to continue to
ask the ukrainians to give Russia part
of their country after all this death
and destruction is not going to happen
to Signal a ceasefire Russia will take
the opportunity to re-arm and come at
him again so we're in it to win it and
the only way you're going to win it is
to break the Russian military and have
somebody in Russia take Putin out
so we're going to says Lindsey Graham
confidently continue pouring billions
into Ukraine until they quote take Putin
out
does Putin know this well we have no
idea we're not allowed to see Russian
media in this country that's too much
information for Americans to handle but
if Putin does know that we plan to kill
him wouldn't he fight back with nuclear
weapons why wouldn't he fight back with
nuclear weapons no one in the United
States seems to be allowed to wonder
that much less have a conversation about
it out loud instead we're treated to
more lectures about democracy Ukraine is
a democracy we're told that's why we're
on the side of Ukraine
the problem is that is a lie Ukraine is
not a democracy Ukraine is a corrupt
one-party State Ukraine has none of the
freedoms that Define democratic
governance freedom of speech freedom of
the press freedom of assembly freedom of
religion
Ukraine is the least free place in all
of Europe and probably for that reason
it is Joe Biden's favorite place
so for those who understand what is
actually happening and what Ukraine is
actually like it is very frustrating to
watch Biden say this again and again it
is galling to be lectured about
democracy by a man who took power in an
election so sketchy that many Americans
don't believe it was even real
Biden has never had the majority of
Americans support for a single day of
the Ukraine war
in fact Joe Biden is far less popular in
the United States than Vladimir Putin is
in Russia that is not an endorsement of
Putin it's just true and it says
everything about Joe Biden's tenuous
legitimacy democracy please we're adults
stop lying to us
so what happens next in this war well
according to our elderly treasury
secretary Janet Yellen the war in
Ukraine will go on forever and so will
our support for zielinski
let me make clear the United States and
the Allies uh our support for Ukraine
will be lasting in his unconditional
unconditional support for Ukraine
unconditional support for a nation most
Americans know nothing about and
couldn't find on a map unconditional
support
that's a profound statement outside of
your immediate family how many people
would you pledge unconditional support
to how many countries would you pledge
unconditional support to
this is insane when you think about it
but the people in charge of This
Disaster aren't thinking the way that
most Americans do the Atlantic magazine
commemorated the anniversary of the war
by commissioning a peace today by Tom
Nichols Nichols is a thoroughly silly
foreign policy establishment parasite
who apparently is taken seriously by
other near to Wells and dumb people in
Washington but the piece is fascinating
in it he inadvertently reveals the point
of this war in the clearest possible
terms quote
now we are faced with the long grind of
defeating moscow's armies and eventually
rebuilding a better world
oh defeating moscow's armies and
building a better world perfect thank
you Tom Nichols adding those items to
this week's to-do list
unspecified in the piece is exactly how
we plan to do this how we plan to defeat
Russia and its Ally China and then build
Utopia the piece is notably light on
details now you'd feel a little better
hearing all this if Tom Nichols and
others like him in Washington had a
track record that suggested they could
do any of this a track record of
competence and success they don't
Nichols himself seems to spend most of
his life arguing with other people on
Twitter he's never achieved anything at
all that we're aware of but then
virtually none of them have achieved
anything
Biden's Chief Ukraine strategist torian
Newland you would not hire her to plan
spring break she couldn't do it she
doesn't have the skills now these very
same people these demonstrably
incompetent people say they plan to
rebuild a better world
all right that seems ambitious how about
starting with Baltimore before moving on
to Total Global transformation shouldn't
we fix the biggest city in Maryland
First
under the leadership of people like Tom
Nichols and Tori Newland neoliberal
Geniuses with grand plans Baltimore has
devolved into third world chaos but then
so has Iraq and so as Libya and so as
every other place these people have
decided to quote rebuild
it should spur a moment of silence and
self-reflection in the U.S state
Department that the moment Western
diplomats and ngos left the country
Afghanistan got safer
there are far fewer killings in Kabul
now than there were 18 months ago
pedestrians at Kabul can walk to dinner
at night without being murdered now that
fact doesn't tell the whole story of
Afghanistan of course
but we shouldn't ignore that fact it
means something if you spend billions
trying to make a place better and it
gets worse you have an obligation to
think about why maybe you're doing it
wrong maybe you're not as powerful and
clever as you thought you were maybe
there's a problem with your formula
but none of this ever occurs to people
like Tom Nichols and Toria Newlin and
for that matter Joe Biden the more
discredited they are the more
self-confident they become they see
every failure as evidence of their
talents are more desperately needed than
ever
what is this
well it's called hubris
hubris is the delusion that causes
people to mistake themselves for God
they imagine they have power and wisdom
and foresight they don't actually
possess that no human does
hubris is a species of mental illness
these people are unwell they're crazy
and there's nothing more dangerous than
that hubris has caused more suffering
than polio it's caused more deaths than
smallpox and apparently we're in the
middle of another epidemic of it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight